Imagine a couple blessed with twin babies
who are conjoint.
Now if they are to be
separated, then one of them is sure to lose
life.
But raising the conjoined twins is
not only difficult for the parents, but even
for the kids themselves!
So what
should be done in this case?
These questions give us goosebumps!
But they are always a part of the medical
field.
And how are the answers to such traumatising
questions found?
Well, although we cannot really answer such
questions completely, but still to
reach the best conclusion, we have the concept
of BIOETHICS coming to our
rescue!
In the previous videos we learned about the
Transgenic organisms which are
produced and used for human benefit.
But the production of transgenic animals
comes at the cost of disturbing the natural
genome of those organisms.
So do you
think this is morally correct?
You may say no!
We should not use organisms for
our selfish motto!
Okay… so how do we test the newer medicines?
As the disease
or disorder intensity is increasing exponentially,
so is the need for newer and
more efficient medicines!
So if there are no model organisms, then testing
medicines will not be possible.
So how will new medicines be discovered and
used?
That indicates the need of using model organisms!
So what should be done ideally?
There is no single answer for this actually.
And
hence, for these types of concerns we have
the field of bioethics.
Now let us first understand what Bioethics
is!
It is simply the area dealing with
ethical issues in the field of Medicine or
any other biological studies.
In this video, let us learn about bioethics
in the field of biotechnology.
Let us begin with the same point that we discussed
a few minutes
back...Transgenic organisms!
Genetic engineering enables us to study the
various genetic disorders.
And for
these types of studies, transgenic animal
models, like the Transgenic mice are
developed.
Transgenic animal models are Developed for
Particular genetic disorder
These animals, as we know are called Genetically
Modified Organisms or GMOs.
And just like animals, plants are also modified.
So the transgenic crops produced
also have qualities that we desire!
Just like the Golden rice for example!
It
contains wholesome amount of Beta-carotene,
which is the precursor of Vitamin
A. When consumed, the compound gets converted
to Vitamin A in the body.
Thus,
the transgenic rice variety is a boon to areas
hit with Vitamin A deficiency.
But if the organisms are so beneficial to
us, then is their production really an
ethical concern?
Yes!
That is the other side of the coin!
GMOs are known to produce several
compounds, among which, a few can be toxic
or allergenic in nature.
We cannot ensure that these untraced compounds
would not harm us.
Thus,
there are several hidden risks attached to
this.
There can be possibilities that the
GMOs turn out to be actually more harmful
rather than being beneficial.
The long
term side effects of GMOs are still unknown.
Also, as we know that transgenic organisms
have a completely different gene pool
from the wild varieties.
So at the species level, we disturb the genetic
composition
of those organisms!
Do we really know what impact this can create
several years
later?
What can happen if the transgenic genes sustain
in the gene pool forever?
And what if natural genes are lost?
There are many other questions that emerge
as we go deeper in this discussion!
Hence, making “transgenic organisms” is
an ethical concern!
So what is the
solution to this?
There is no fixed solution for this, but yes,
there are few
regulatory bodies which glance at the various
activities in the field of
biotechnology.
Now let us talk about one more hot topic in
bioethics...that is Cloning!
We know that cloning in biotechnology deals
with the process of making exact
copies of biomolecules or organisms.
How about Human cloning?
The idea sounds cool!
But that is not so great in
reality!
Preparing human clones without regulation
would definitely lead to
serious concerns, like overpopulation, increase
in diseases, exhaustion of limited
resources and many more!
Also, this can act against the balance of
nature.
We
know that nature promotes variation in gene
pool of organisms.
Cloning can lead
to utilisation of the same gene pool constantly,
thus leading to a loss of vigour in
the genes.
And there are many other issues which pop
up with the process of making clones!
Thus, the question whether cloning is favourable
or not still remains unanswered!
For all such questions, which literally churn
our minds, the only option that comes
to our rescue is Bioethics!
There are several rules and regulatory laws
laid under
bioethics, that help us make wise decisions
as we stumble upon heart wrenching
obstacles!